اهلا بكم لا يستقر صناع القرار في واشنطن
على كلمه سواء بشان الازمه الخليجيه فما
ان يطلق الرئيس دونالد ترامب واحده من
تصريحاته او تغريداته المتعلقه بوقف تمويل
الارهاب حتى تلحق به تصريحات كتلك التي
صدرت عن وزير الدفاع جيمز ماتيس لتست درك
عليها انحيازها ضد قطر وتتحدث عن ضروره
التهدئه والحل من خلال الحوار خلافا
للتردد الامريكي بدا الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان واضحا بخصوص الازمه فالحصان
المضروب من دول خليجيه على قطر مرفو
وغير انساني والحل لا يكون الا بالحوار
بدوره لم يبتعد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتن عن هذا المنطق مذكرا من اتخذ قرار
الحصار بانه اضر بالبيت الخليجي وبقضايا
تعني كل اعضائه ومنها المساعي الجاريه
لانهاء الصراع في سوريا محمد ابراهيم
والتقرير التالي ثم نبدا
النقاش ما تزال الازمه الخليجيه بعيده عن
اي خطوات للحل رغم جميع المساعي الاقليميه
والدوليه للتهدئه مع دخول الازمه اسبوعها
الثانيه واستمرار الحصار المفروض على
الدوحه برا وجوا وبحرا ترتفع اصوات
الوسطاء داعيه لتخفيف اثاره وتبعات ما
يجري لا سما على عامه الناس وتحث على تبني
لغه الحوار بدلا من التصعيد والتصلب في
معالجه القضايا العالقه بين الاطراف تفعلت
الدوحه ايجاب مع تلك الدعوات وابدت
استعدادها لحوار يحترم استقلالها وسيادتها
بينما بدا الحصار يحصد انتقادات واسعه
نظرا لما تضمنه من قرارات لا انسانيه
واخرى جعلت عواصم كباريس وبرلين ولندن
تخشى على مصالحها في المنطقه تركيا
استشعرت خطر الحصار منذ انطلاقه وها هو
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان يضع النقاط على
الحروف بقوله انما تتعرض له قطر اشبه
بعقوبه اعدام مشيرا الى ان العقوبات
المفروضه على قطر لا تتوافق مع القيم
الانسانيه
والاسلاميه
اار تبدو قطر الان وكانها تتعرض لحكم
اعدام عن طريق قطع المواد الغذائيه
والعلاج عنها يحاولون خنقها عن طريق
الحصار الجوي ايضا وعلى الرغم من جميع
اواصر القرابه وعلاقات الصداقه بين هذه
الدول فانه تم تنفيذ كل ذلك واكررها مره
اخرى على ملك السعوديه خادم الحرمين
الشريفين كزعيم اكبر دوله في الخليج ان
يحل هذه الازمه وان يتولى الرياده في
تنفيذ الخطوات في هذا الاطار على صعيد
متصل طالب وزير الخارجيه البريطاني بورس
جونسون باتخاذ اجراءات فوريه لتخفيف
الحصار ووقف التصعيد وللعمل على الوصول
الى حل متفاوض بشانه وطالبت منظمه العفو
الدولي برفع الحصار فورا في مقابل هذه
المواقف كان لافتا في نظر كثيرين تباين
التصريحات الامريكيه بشان الازمه الخليجيه
ففي وقت وصف فيه وزير الدفاع جيمس ماتس
الحصار على قطر بانه وضع معقد للغايه
وبالتزامن مع اشاده وزير الخارجيه ريكست
لرسن في تصريحات عده بموقف قطر في مجال
مكافحه الارهاب يصرح الرئيس ترامب بخلاف
اعضاء فريقه في الاداره الامريك
ذاكرا قطر مرارا في سياق الحديث عن جهود
تجفيف منابع الارهاب الماليه وبين هذا
الموقف وذاك تكاد الرؤيه الامريكيه تتحول
الى لغز اختلفت في تحليله التاويلات
والتوظيفات يحتفي ترامب بالجهود الجاريه
لوقف تمويل الارهاب ولا يخفي سروره
بالصفقات التي ستجلب لبلاده الاف الوظائف
لكنه بدا في الان ذاته على مسافه من فريقه
الذي ينظر كل عضو فيه من دائره تخصصه سواء
اكان دفاعا او خارجيه الى مخاطر التوتر
الذي يسود البيت الخليجي فضلا عن تعطيل
مساعي التهدئه
والمراهنة للك من واشنطن باتريك يرس
المسؤول السابق في وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه اهلا بكما وابدا معك سيد باتريك
ثس في واشنطن كيف يمكن ان نفهم هذا
التباين في التصريحات الامريكيه هذا المد
والجزر في التصريحات الامريكيه حيال هذه
الازمه يعني ترامب يقول شيئا ترسن يقول
شيئا اخر وماتيس يقول شيئا ثالثا ما حقيقه
الموقف الامريكي
نعم هذا في الواقع سؤال وجيه للغايه وهو
سؤال يطرح في كل انحاء واشنطن
حاليا وان افضل تفسير ممكن لهذه التناقضات
سمعناه من قبل رئيس مجلس النواب السيد بول
راين وهو من حزب الرئيس قال ان الرئيس
ترامب يقضي قضى طوال حياته كمطور للعقارات
وهو بالتالي بكل بساطه لا يفهم كيف تعمل
الحكومه اي حكومه ولو ما دفعنا بالامور
فاننا نستطيع ان نقول بان ما قاله وزير
الخارجيه
ترسن هو الذي يمثل موقف حكومه الولايات
المتحده وان تغريدات السيد ترامب
وملاحظاته هي مجرد ملاحظات او تعليقات
ولكنها في الواقع لا تشكل اي شيء يشبه او
يمكن يكون على شكل سياسه وبالتالي فان ما
قاله
وزير الخارجيه بانه سيتعاون مع قطر
لمعالجه هذه القضايا الخاصه بالاتهامات
موجهه حول غسيل الاموال وتمويل
الارهاب ودع الدول الاخرى الى ان تخفف او
ترفع الحصار الذي يسبب مشاكل انسانيه
ويؤثر على الاعمال ويؤثر حتى على العمليات
الامنيه الولايات المتحده وبالتالي هذه
الواقعيه السياسه الامريكيه
وان التعليقات التي يضعها الرئيس لا تساعد
هذه السياسه ولكن بصراحه اعتقد ان ذلك
سببه قله خبره ومعرفه الرئيس بشؤون الحكم
لا يفهم ما يمثله ملاحظاته من فوضى او
ارتباك لكن سيد روس يعني رغم ما تقوله من
او ما اشرت اليه من قله خبره الرئيس
الامريكي و رعونه الرئيس الامريكي في
اداره شؤون البلاد ومن ان تيلرسون هو الذي
يمثل الموقف الرسمي
الامريكي هل هل كانت اذا كان فعلا
الاعتقاد في امريكا بان قطر مموله للارهاب
هل كانت الولايات المتحده بحاجه لاشاره من
دول الخليجيه او من دوله كال الامارات
مثلا لان
تتحرك كلا الاتهامات
الاتهامات طرحت وقدمت هذه الاتهامات وذكرت
علنا واثنين او وثلاثه امريكان شاركوا في
تقديم هذه الاتهامات فاذا تذكرون قبل
سنتين مساعد وزير الماليه طرح مثل هذه
الاتهامات بنفسه وغالبا وقبل فتره اخرى
نجد ان الحقيقه لا تكن مهمه بما هو مهم
الفكره والانطباع الذي يحصل عن الحقيقه
وبالتالي هذا الموضوع مطروح اذا وان
السعوديه والامارات العربيه تسببتا في
الازمه والولايات المتحده لابد ان تتعامل
مع الازمه هذه و لو ان اي هذه من ه
الهامات قد ثبتت كلا حسب رؤيتي لم اشاهد
اي شيء من قبل الحكومه الامريكيه يطلب
القاء قبض على اي اشخاص في قطر
مثلا ولكن القصه المذكوره وهي انه مع
الاسف لا يمكن تجاهل بان بما ما حصل من
اتهامات ولا بد من التجاوب المجابه عليها
ا سيد سامي النصف في الكويت تلك الازمه
التي بدات
بفبركه تصريحات نسبت لامير قطر وصلت الان
الى هذه الاتهامات الامريكيه وان لم تكن
مباشره لقطر بتمويل
الارهاب هل من صله او علاقه تراها ما بين
المبتدا والخبر بمعنى يعني صله تراها ما
بين فبركت هذه التصريحات ومن ثم الازمه
الخليجيه والان بين هذه الاتهامات
الامريكيه والموقف
الامريكي اختي الفاضله انا اعتقد ان انا
امام مع
خليجي واشكال خليجي والحل يجب ان ياتي من
الخليج انتظار حل من الشرقي او القرب
الولايات المتحده او روسيا او غيرها من
دول اقليميه لم يثبت جدو بالمشاكل
الاقليميه الاخرى بالعراق وفي سوريا وفي
ليبيا وفي اليمن وغيرها وبالتالي انا
اتصور انه علينا ان نبحث عن الحل
ضمن المجتمع الخليجي وعلينا كذلك ان نكون
حذرين جدا من قضيه التنابز بقضيه الارهاب
لانه المجتمع الدولي المجتمع العالمي
يقاسي الامرين من الارهاب وبالتالي ليس من
السهوله ان نلقي بالتهم اتجاه هذا الطرف
او ذاك فيما يخص الارهاب ثم نندم لاحقا
لانه هناك قوانين وتشريعات بالولايات
المتحده وحتى بالدول الاوروبيه وغيرها
شديده اتجاه دعم الارهاب وبالتالي علينا
ان نكون حذرين جدا في قضيه التنابز هذه
التهمه الان الاشكال واضح المعالم واتصور
انه مجلس التعاون به بالماده العاشره ما
يكفل السعي لحل هذا الاشكال هناك بالماده
العاشره من ميثاق الجي سي سي هيئه فرض
هيئه لحل النزاعات التي تنشا وقد يعني تم
اللجوء لهذا الامر في ابريل 86 عندما احتد
الخلاف بين دولتين خليجيتين فتم التدخل
وحل هذا الاشكال وبالتالي نامل ونامل انه
يعني بالنهايه نرجع الى مجلسنا والى
محاوله حل الاشكال بعيدا عن يعني جهات
علمنا انها تتكلم كثيرا بالحلول ولا تعمل
شيء بدلاله ان الاشكالات القائمه بالوطن
العربي والنيران المشتعله لا زالت مشتعله
بعد ست سنوات من بدها وبعد ست سنوات من
وعود كثيره باطفائها من هذا المنطلق سيد
فيروس يعني هناك جهات كثيره تتكلم ولا
تفعل
شيئا رغم ما افادنا به السيد سامي النصف
بان الحل يجب ان يكون ينطلق من الخليج
كانت هناك تصريحات تتحدث بمنطق ايجابي
تصريحات امريكيه تحدثت بمنطق ايجابي عن
ضروره حل الازمه عبر الحوار لماذا لم
تتحرك الولايات المتحده لم تقم باي خطوه
ملموسه عمليه ربما
ل المساعده في الوساطه التي تقوم بها
الكويت هذا ايضا سؤال وجيه للغايه وهو
والسؤال انا لست متاكدا لدي جواب جيد له
ولكن اعتقد ان جزء من الجواب يكمن في
حقيقه انه في هذا الوقت في هذه اللحظه
وزير الخارجيه ليس لديه كبار موظفين
يساعدونه و البيت الابيض فشل في تعيين اي
شخص في الوظائف الرئيسيه في وزاره
الخارجيه وبالتالي فان الوزير يحمل كل
العبا لوحده وان كل ازمه في العالم ت هو
وما المانع ان ان ياتي الوزير وزير
الخارجيه نفسه الى
المنطقه السبب هو ان وزير الخارجيه هو
فعلا لوحده يواجه كل المشاكل وكل القضايا
والدول الاخرى وبالتالي هناك كثير على عب
فذلك هناك ازمات كثيره في العالم في الوقت
ذاته في اوروبا وفي كوريا الشماليه وبخروج
بريطانيا من انتخابات والانتخابات الطنيه
وبغياب كبار موظفين في وزاره الخارجيه فان
هذا يعني ان وزير الخارجيه عليه ان ان
يتخلى عن كل قضا الوسائل الاخرى وياتي الى
المنطقه للتركيز على عليها وطبعا هذا هو
امر غير جيد لكن هذا وضعنا وبالتالي نامل
ان دول الخليج تستطيع ان تحل المشكله فيما
بينها وان مع الاسف ارى انك شعور بالاحباط
من جانب الدول المجاوره لقطر اذ انهم قد
بداوا بعمل واجراءات وهم يتوقعون ان قطر
سوف تستسلم تستسلم وتخلى عن سيادتها ولكن
قطر لم تفعل ذلك وبالتالي فهم حاليا
يفكرون ما هي الخطوه التاليه يمكن ان
يقوموا بها ويبدو انهم لم يحصلوا لم
يبدو كانهم وصل الطريق مسدود وحقيقه ان
قطر لم تستسلم ولم تتخلى فهم عليهم الان
يجد طريقه لطريقه التعامل مع هذا الحصار
وهذا مركز او مصدر احباط كبير لهم وكما
قلت ان ضعف الولايات المتحده اليوم ه لسنا
كبار موظفين في وزاره الخارجيه ولسنا كبار
موظفين في وزاره الدفاع وان البيت
الابيض ليس فيه موظفين كافين وبالتالي ليس
في الاشخاص المناسبين لمثل هذه الاعمال
وبالتالي هنا عف على مقاطعتك سيد يروس فقط
لضيق الوقت سيد سامي النصف يعني على ذكر
الخطوه
التاليه من الواضح انه اصبح هناك مقاربه
للارهاب تتبناها الاطراف الخليجيه
المقاطعه لقطر وربما تتشارك معها اسرائيل
في تلك المقاربه ربما لانها تعني حركه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه حما برايك الى اي مدى
يمكن
ان او
ربما تتبنى هذهه الاطراف الخليجيه هذه
المقاربه
رسميا اختي الفاضله هذا تشعب بالقضيه انا
اتصور القضيه عليها ان ترجع الى الاصل
والاصل ان علينا ان نحل هذا الاشكال ضمن
القرف المغلقه وان من المحرج جدا من
المحرج جدا امام شعوبنا الخليجيه ان نعلم
بان هذا الاشكال قد حل بضغوط خارجيه من
هذه الدوله او تلك اعتقد هذا الامر غير
مقبول ولدينا من الحكمه لدى القيادات
الخليجيه لحل هذا الاشكال دون انتظار ذقو
من الخارج يتبقى ان دول مجلس التعاون لن
تنتظر قضيه التخبط اذا جازت التسميه
القائم ما بين القياده وبين الخارجيه
امريكيه لحل هذا الاشكال القضيه اكبر من
حتى اشكال خليجي اعتقد ان السلم العالمي
سيقل عندما نعلم ان هناك عده رؤوس للسياسه
الخارجيه نامل ان يعني يحل هذا الاشكال
وعلينا ان نعلم ان كل يوم يمر يزيد
الاشكال سوءا وبالتالي حتى يزيد الاشكال
تعقيدا ووسائل الحل متعدده وكثيره على
الجامعه العربيه ان تتحرك كذلك هناك
التفاوض هناك المساعي الحميده الوساطه
التحقيق التوفيق التحكيم كلها وسائل خلقت
ضمن المجتمع الدولي وضمن المجتمع العربي
لحل اشكال اشكالات اكثر تعقيدا من هذا
وبالتالي ما نامل ان نرى هذه السحابه وقد
ابتعدت علينا ان نعلم اختي الفاضله ان دول
الخليج مستقصده ان تفرق دول الخليج يضعفنا
جميعا ان رس الصفوف لدى دول والخليج
يقوينا جميعا هذه البديهيات عليها ان
تتصدر المشهد وان نرى هذا الاشكال سريعا
نعم خارج منطقه الخليج وان نبدا بالتركيز
على عدم تكراره علينا ان نخلق او نلجا الى
ميثاق المجلس التعاون اللي يطلب خلق هيئات
لحل المنازعات حتى لا يتكرر هذا الامر
وانا اعتقد جازما بان هذا الاشكال سيذهب
سريعا وستختفي اثار ولدينا من الحكمه ما
يضمن لنا هذا الامر وكذلك لدينا ادله
وقرائن شاهدناها في دول عربيه راهنت على
اطراف اخرى لحل مشاكلها وبقيت الاشكالات
تزداد يوما بعد يوم اشكرك من الكويت سامي
النصف الكاتب صحفي الكويتي وكذلك اشكر من
واشنطن باتريك روس المسؤول السابق في
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه